This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's a sweltering June morning in Basel, Switzerland. Trams roll through the streets. Some people get their first coffee, while others cool off in the Rhine. I'm coming up here to the Munsterplatz. This is the big cathedral in the square. That's for Porter and Basel resident, Gabe Bullard.
There's a group here of people in their traditional outfits. the dark pants, white shirts, suspenders with idle vise. But this isn't everyday Basel. Gabe is attending a celebration of Swiss folk music that happens every three years, called Jolterfest. Yotlerfest is what I imagine people outside of Switzerland think the country is like every day. It's like a snow globe idea of Switzerland. People are in their long-sleeved traditional clothes,
sitting at long wooden tables, eating meals that are mostly melted cheese, even though we're in a record heat wave. A couple times, I passed by one of those wood cutouts where you put your face through to take a photo. These are of a man and woman in traditional Swiss clothes out in the mountains. And everywhere I go, from every direction, I can hear yodling. Some people here have been yodling all their lives,
like Anita Fuliger from Central Switzerland. Yeah, I'm a mountain girl. I have seven sister and brothers, and then we take yoddling and music for a hobby and family. Others are here to just bask in the sounds, like Francisco Morgan and Gabriela Santa Maria. I've always find it's very attractive, very beautiful, all that has to do with folklore. In any culture, folklore is like the best thing ever. Francisco and Gabriella live in the area, and I met them as they were walking between food stalls
set up to look like mountain chalets. They'd just come from a yodeling class, their first time trying it. It was wonderful. Thank you so much. Yodlerfest is at its core, a celebration of an old and beloved folk tradition. Some of the melodies drifting out from the street corners and buildings are the same ones you could hear in a small mountain town,
hundreds of years ago. But beyond Yodlerfest and the streets of Basel, Yodeling has had a much bigger and much more international arc, because in the early 19th century, yodeling broke containment. This very Swiss tradition escaped the Alps, traveled across the Atlantic, and helped define a quintessentially American style of music.
Most of us know what a yodel sounds like, but maybe not how it's made. That unmistakable sound of the yodel is the result of a physiological flip that happens inside the sense. singer's body. Yodel is a singing technique where we use the different registers. So for example, the head voice or the chest voice, and very typical for yodeling is to switch between that to yawr. Nadja Rass is one of the leading voices, metaphorically and literally, of Swiss yodeling today. The register switch is something that happens naturally, even accidentally, like if your voice
cracks while you're shouting. And people around the world have been making music with this vocal quirk for centuries. In Iran, it's called Tahrir singing. In Georgia, Krimanchuli. Within the Alps, different countries and even different valleys have their own unique versions of this singing. There's a classic Swiss yodel, which is markedly different than, say, an Austrian yodel. Despite what we know about its regional variations, the origins of the alpine yodel are shrouded in mountain mist. History is just a loose end. It's in the dark. We cannot say it goes back to this and that century because we don't have written documents about it. We don't have artifacts like with musical instruments. This is Janik Wei, a musicologist who has studied alpine music. He also plays is the Alphorn, you know the horns that the guys play in the Ricola commercials.
Yannick says that some of the earliest yoddlers were probably cattle herders in the Alps. And one of the earliest possible references to yodeling is a document from around the year 400 that describes some Alpine singing as, quote, Yuulate Carmine Diaboli, which an Austrian folklorist in the 20th century translated as Toodle of a Devlish song. More reliable documentation picks up around the 16th century. century, when travelers through the Alps described a type of music unique to the region. In French, it would come to be known as Rondevaish, and in German, Kourain.
In English, it's usually translated as cattle call, and this is sort of a name for a bunch of different music. Some of it yodeled, some of it sung maybe without yodeling, and some of it played on the alpine horn or on different instruments. The reason cattle herders were devilishly tootling up in the mountains is debated. Musicologists think yodeling could have been a way for those herders to communicate across long distances. So on the Alps, it was a very scarcely populated territory. If you were working on the mountains, herding animals, it was maybe a very lonely thing to do. And you needed something to communicate over distances, both to communicate to, to other people, that you are fine, that you are in good health, and so on, and also to call
cows and other animals. Another theory is that yodeling was part of religious ceremonies. For ritual purposes, for sort of, we could today say magic. And there's also the fact that it's just fun to yodel. Imagine, you're out, miles from your home with only the company of your herd. You can shout into the mountain air, and you're a little. echo answers back. For centuries, these yodels bounced around the Alps, entertaining lonely herders, maybe being sung in mountain taverns or around a family dinner table. But in the 1700s,
a shift came that would help launch the yodel from a pastoral pastime into a global sensation. What that change looked like was a surge of interest from people who weren't herding cows. In the 18th and 19th centuries, European travelers were embarking on grand tours of the continent. Europe's young elite would drink wine, study art, and generally acquire a sense of worldliness to flaunt back home. Basically, a regency-era gap year. Popular destinations included Rome, Paris, and the snowy expanse of the Swiss Alps. And with wealthy foreigners arriving to take in the sights and sounds of Switzerland, Jordlers couldn't help but notice. It was also then an opportunity for people to make some money by people.
performing in touristic locations on the countryside, also on mountains. With tourism, yodeling transformed from a cattle call into a performance. Singers worked the yodel into songs, singing a verse and then yodeling a chorus, what's called a yodel-eatel-eat, compared to a natur-yodel done without lyrics. Performers also took some festive liberties. No true cattle herder would wear something special to sing to their cows. But these performance yoddlers wanted to lay it on. thick for the tourists. They put on their troch, the traditional folksy outfits, to play up the exoticism
of their homeland. Pretty soon, there were suspended yodlers at every turn. That also led to a backlash by the authorities, where there were too many of these beggars going around with a horn or just singing, well, it became a bit of annoying to the tourists. In his book A Tramp Abroad, Mark Twain writes about a hike in Switzerland, where he heard a shepherd yodeling. He gives us a shepherd yodeling. He gives the shepherd some money to keep singing. He does the same with another shepherd later on. And another. Then another. Eventually, Twain pays the locals to stop singing. He writes, there is somewhat too much of the yodeling in the Alps. Luckily, not everyone agreed with Mark Twain. Tourists to the Alps heard yodeling and were captivated. It was this otherworldly echoing sound, unlike anything
they'd ever heard. Some people were so taken that they wanted to find a way to write down the yodel and bring it back with them. Unfortunately for them, yodeling was an oral tradition without any sheet music. We have really funny exchange of letters, you know, where somebody from the city in Zurich was asking his friend to deliver a notation
of one of these cattle calls and said, you know, I've been trying so hard to get one. But if I ask the people here in the village for it, they just laugh at me, they just make fun of me. and when they're singing it goes on for an hour and how am I supposed to write that down? People did eventually figure out how to write down a yodel. And pretty soon, the sounds of the Alps drifted out into the wider world.
Yodling reached Switzerland's close neighbors in continental Europe and then further into the British Isles. But nowhere did it take hold more forcefully than across the ocean in the United States, where it was about to create a new, very American genre of music. music. Yodeling first reached the United States in the early 1800s when troops of European singers traveled across the Atlantic to perform for American audiences. They came with their special outfits and traditional songs, ready to delight the crowds with the exotic sounds of the Alps. It's worth noting this probably wouldn't have been the first time Americans were
hearing a vocal flip in music. Many people were already familiar with the field holler, a way of singing practiced by enslaved people working on farms and plants. representations in the South. Here is an example recorded in 1939, performed by Thomas J. Marshall. But this distinct Alpine style of yodling took off in part because European yodlers were offering a performance, a costumed spectacle. And before long, Swiss, German, and Austrian yodlers became a fixture of the American entertainment landscape. American imitators also jumped on the bandwagon, and over the course of the 19th and early 20th centuries, yodeling became fully incorporated into the racial melting pot of American entertainment.
Yodling was everywhere. It became a staple of blackface minstrel shows. At the same time, white performers also imitated the field holler, and black musicians yodled on the vaudeville stage. The yodel was one influence of many being mixed and matched by American entertainers. Then a singing railroad brakeman from Mississippi came along and took the yodel to New Heights. Those are the dulcet tones of a man named Jimmy Rogers. Rogers grew up across the southern United States,
working on the railroad and playing music whenever he could. At the time, Rogers perceived of himself just as a popular entertainer. He listened to everything he could get his hands on. He toured with different groups. He was always willing to perform if someone was willing to pay him. Jasselan Neal is a professor and historian who focuses on American popular music. She says he was a savvy entertainer with an ear for whatever might get an audience. He played what was called at the time hillbilly music, a catch-all term for music from the
white working class South. But he also heard folk and blues music while traveling around. He picked up work songs from black colleagues on the railroad. He played medicine shows and minstrel shows. He had a stint with a jazz band and later a string band. Jimmy was a jack of all trades and in 1927 he went into a recording studio and and laid down something unexpected. An original song he'd been working on called Tea for Texas. You can really hear the blues influence. This is the style of music Rogers would have heard
played mostly by black musicians all through the South. The songs themselves that Jimmy Rogers is recording are very much in what we would call a blues form. They use the rhymed couplets. They use the use of a refrain. They come with the same chord progressions. Now, he modified them here and there, but again, a regular listener on the street could listen to this and say,
oh, yeah, I hear the blues form in there. I hear a 12-bar blues chord progression. So that blues song form was present, and the yodel was added into it. Rogers never explained where he got his yodling. He surely heard all types of head chest register flips, including from black yoddlers on vaudeville stages. But his style traces traces back.
back to alpine singers. I'm pretty sure from having listened to a bunch of the source material that Jimmy Rogers was borrowing a vaudeville stylized performance technique that is absolutely linked to Tyrolian yodling and is a European import. When Jimmy Rogers recorded an alpine yodel over a 12-bar blues progression, he set off a chemical reaction in the music industry. His sound wasn't quite the blues or the standard hillbilly music of the time, or anything else. It was what we would now call
country. And people loved it. It absolutely was astonishing how popular this music was. He caught the attention of a broad population of people who were really connected to his music in a way that I think it's very hard
for a regular listener today to think. We'd have to think about a superstar today at the level of global attention to match what Jimmy Rogers was able to do with the American population as a vernacular performer in the late 1920s. The stories that we hear are that people would literally go down to their local store, their local general store to get their daily supplies and a Jimmy Rogers record, whatever had come out. Rogers wasn't the very first to combine blues and yodling.
The idea had already been percolating for a while, and a black composer named Clarence Williams had written a song called Yodeling Blues earlier in the 20s. But Jimmy Rogers was the first one to turn that comment. combination into a commercial hit. Today, Jimmy Rogers is known as the father of country music. Rogers sits alongside a very few number of artists like the Carter family who pioneered the genre by blending all sorts of American influences. Blues, field hollering, old British and Irish folk songs, and Roger's thing was his yodel.
Roger's producer called his first big hit, T for Texas, a blue yodel. And that was just Blue Yodel number one. Rogers would record a dozen more, including one with Lewis Armstrong on trumpet. Other performers wanted to do what was popular, and Jimmy Rogers was popular. So before long, Yoteling was all over the proto-country scene. Lots of hillbilly artists used the yodel, finding all sorts of ways to catch people's attention. Like Mary Jane and Carolyn DeZerick, sisters from Minnesota who became popular on the radio in the 1930s. While the Dzeric sisters were doing that, Gene Autry was yodeling his way into Hollywood.
Autry became known as the singing cowboy, and the films he was in shaped the iconography of the West, with his big hat, his broken heart, and his rhinestone suit. Get this, rhinestones have an alpine origin too. The name refers to clear stones that were found in the Rhine River, which originates in Switzerland. The word was applied to glass and plastic beads later on. There's not as much alpine-style yodeling in modern country music compared to the music made in the 20s and 30s. But what has carried over is the head chest register flip. That little flip, heard in the yodel and the field holler, remains an essential part of a country musician's repertoire.
It conveys the emotion of a lonesome cowboy, borrowing some of that heartbreaking pastoral quality of the mountains. For example, with Hank Williams' version of the song Lovesick Blues. I got a feeling of the blues. Oh, Lord, since my baby said goodbye. In that song, he uses a vocal break where he sings a word. And then he splits his voice across his vocal break up to a high register, comes back down and repeats that process in the middle of a word. So it's a little bit of a different technique than what Jimmy Rogers was doing.
But again, if we're taking that broader categorization of yodels as singing with multiple vocal registers, then Hank Williams is absolutely doing it. Today, the influence of yodeling has become so woven into the fabric of country music that most of us wouldn't even identify it as yodeling anymore. The vocal flip, the crying steel guitar, it just sounds like country. When you look at the dramatic evolution of yodeling in America, how it jumped from vaudeville performances to cowboy films and the world's biggest country stages, it seems a little odd that yodeling back in Switzerland often looks and sounds like it did in the 1800s, people in traditional outfits singing traditional songs, evoking a pastoral Swiss yesteryear. There's a reason today's Swiss yodeling still feels so traditional and nostalgic. In the 1940s, while Jean Autry was yodling in his rhinestone, Switzerland was having a very different experience.
Europe was embroiled in the Second World War, and Switzerland wanted to avoid any association with Germany. One way to do this was to distinguish themselves as much as possible as different and separate from their Nazi neighbors. Here's Yannick Way again. Switzerland had this so-called geistigal Landesfurtiguan, this somewhat spiritual defense of the nation, where yodeling became important as something that distinguished Switzerland from its German-speaking neighbors,
even though maybe from the musical tradition we're much closer than you think. The message was very much that we may speak German, but we are not Germans. Our yodel sounds nothing like their yodel. So please, for the love of God, leave us out of this. One weapon in this cultural defense was a yodling textbook published in 1943. That book is called Oh, Christ, okay.
Aingenurschencher Yodler Varban Shulung's Grundlanga for Yodlerin and un Yodler. Also known as the Swiss Yodeling Association Training Fundamentals for Yodeling Women
and Yodeling Men. The book, whose name I said before, perfectly, laid out some standards for Swiss Yodeling, not Bavarian Yodeling, not Austrian, just pure Swiss yodeling. It said which melodies to sing and which techniques to use. There's even like on one of the first page and says everything on Swiss in Yodling has to be eradicated.
In addition to the book, the Yodling Association put on contests where judges would favor certain types of yodels over others. And for many years, singers tended to stick to a textbook jury-approved set of melodies, sounds and flourishes. The Yodling Association did keep people yodeling, but this focus on a regulation Swiss style narrowed what had been a pretty diverse tradition, and the influence of these regulations and norms lasted long after the war was over. Still, you can't keep a good yodel down,
and today Switzerland is enjoying a surge of interest in yodling, especially with younger generations, who want to play with a vocal technique that is, let's face it, Very fun. I talked to Nadia Rass about this at Yodlerfest. And one thing that has surprised me so far walking around is how many young people there are of yodeling. Yes, yes, yes. Is that a change you've seen recently?
I think it's a change which developed since three, four, five years. So I think it's much the yodel community, it's much younger than five years before. What do you think that means for the future of yodling? This is a very good sign, of course. So I think, so it means that yodel will stay alive. Nadia has been part of this preservation. In 2018, students at the Hoksho-Lutzerne specifically requested a college-level yodeling program, and she was selected to run it.
The program isn't alpine cosplay. It honors the tradition of yodeling while pushing it forward. Students study the history of yodeling and what it sounded like before the rules and competitions and clubs. They listen to archival recordings, to American country songs, and they write and perform new yodels. On the day I visited, students put on a concert that included a song written by Nadia.
One alum of the program is Andrea Kutel, who's now yodling with her band Quartz. And she also blends yodeling with jazz, classical music, and other genres. I had the opportunity to yodel with the percussionist from Cuba. so it fits with other type of music as well. So it's really cool to interact with different types of music. The reinvention of yodeling doesn't stop with Nadja and her students.
For every traditional melody being honored and preserved in a Swiss yodling club, there's another young artist taking the yodel and doing something entirely different, like the Swiss Spanish artist called Vagamundos, who samples yodels in reggatone tracks. When I listened to Baillard Dembo When I listen to Vagamundoz, ... When I listened to Vagamundoz,
or Andrea's band Quartz, or any of these other new artists, I can't help but feel a sense of deja vu. Like what happened to yodeling in America might be happening now in Switzerland. Like Jimmy Rogers before them, Switzerland's new generation of yodlers is taking the yodel,
flipping it on its head, and possibly changing music forever. After the break, some of our favorite yodeling deep cuts. So Gabe, this story had some really amazing archival recordings, but there are also a lot of yodels that got left on the cutting room floor, and we wanted to play a few of them. Yes, as I was reporting the story, I got so fascinated by this era between when yodeling first came to the U.S.
and when it ended up in country music. And so these European yodlers, they came over like in the early 1800s. The blue yodel from Jimmy Rogers, that's 1927. So there's like a century of yodeling just kind of bouncing around America at the time. Totally, totally. Okay, let's learn more. Yeah, so this really blew my mind that the first known recordings of yodeling were made in the United States. This is something that Yannick, who we heard from in the story, was telling me.
And he sent me this. It's George P. Watson as the performer. And this is from the late 1890s. I'll find specialty with Iodo sung by Mr. George D. Watson Edison record. Well, so that was not recorded in Switzerland, but recorded in America. That is so amazing to me. Yeah, the very first recording of a yodel was from 1892, I believe, also made in the United States. But this one was definitely one of the earliest.
It makes sense on the one hand because the technology. was in the U.S. There were all these people yodeling and everything. But then also the Swiss experts I talked to were intrigued by this because we don't have an equivalent from the Alps at the time. Like there's sheet music maybe, but it's an oral tradition. It's evolving over time. And it's not captured at any kind of snapshot like that until we have an ability to record
it. So we don't really know what yodeling was sounding like anywhere else in the world at this time. That's amazing. So what other yodels do you have for me? So this next one comes from the 20th century when a lot of popular performers are sort of using the yodel as part of their toolkit. And this is from 1924. It's fascinating. It's a group called the seven musical magpies. And it's called the Calliope song because they're not just yodling, but they're imitating the Calliope, that big steam powered like circus pipe organ.
I love that. Yeah. I really enjoy that one. I love that one of the big influences here is technology. Like the calliope was the sensation. Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're like beatboxing. You know, like they're like imitating the sound of an instrument.
Yeah. Yeah, these singers, they think, you know what sounds like a calliope yodeling. Yeah, exactly. And that's some amazing vocal technique, which is also something that a lot of the Swiss yoddlers I talked to were really impressed by that they hear, you know, we heard the Zurich sisters, too, in the story. that they've heard some of these yodels and are impressed at the technique and everything, especially given, you know, these aren't people learning it from their, you know, from their families out in the Alps, you know, passing down from generation to generation. These are entertainers sort of doing what's popular, picking up the trade from others.
And what about the other yodeling blues singers? Like you mentioned in the story that Jimmy Rogers was the first person, you know, to kind of hit it big combining blues and yodeling. But he wasn't the first to do it, right? Right. So Jimmy Rogers, you know, he has that sort of alpine-derived yodels, sung over blues chords. But that basic mix of blues and yodeling had been tested and recorded. There's the song I mentioned, the yodeling blues.
It's written by Clarence Williams and it's sung by Sarah Martin and Eva Taylor. And it was recorded in the 20s. That's really nice. It's not quite as yodeling as some of the other. but I enjoy the tone of it. Yeah, it's not the full-on little old lady-hoo style, you know, that Jebby Rogers was doing, but it does have that melody of the yodel. And lyrically, the song is wistful and romantic, like a lot of these yodling songs.
And that's something the yodel certainly evokes. The other thing that this song speaks to is an undercurrent throughout the history of country music, which is the erasure of the way black artists contributed to the origins of the genre. The seven musical magpies, Clarence Williams, Sarah Martin, Eva Taylor. these were all black artists and they're playing with the same influences as Jimmy Rogers. They're doing it earlier than him. But as the record industry built up, they were not the ones ultimately to profit from it. Yeah, it's another story that we hear over and over again across all of recorded music.
Well, this was so fascinating, Gabe. I love this tour through the yodel and these sort of leftover yodels on the cutting room floor. Such a fun story. Thank you for bringing it to us. Thanks a lot, Roman. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Gabe Bullard and edited by Kelly Prime. by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real with help from Mia Byrne and APM. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha.
Special thanks this week to Linda Golden for interpretation help. Gabe actually has a new book called Against Convenience, which is out now. It's an exploration of the modern convenience culture, and I can't wait to read it. It is right up my alley and probably yours too. Cathy II is our executive producer. Kurt Kolsted is our digital director. Delaney Hall is a senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher John
Vincent, Vivian Lay, Lashemaddon, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallin and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI. at 99 p.r.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.